citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for She-Hulk episode 8 today listen I
have to get this off my chest uh this is
not a joke many of you guys have been a
long time follower we'll know like my
favorite beanie has always been that
that Daredevil beanie I have spent the
better part of the last hour scouring
this entire place they started helping
out I have no idea where it is and I
have dreamed of the moment where
Daredevil finally returned and I could
be wearing my favorite beanie to my
favorite Marvel character and I have no
clue where it is and now I have to just
let it all go because it doesn't really
matter because it's just a beanie but I
feel like there's some of you who will
understand this stress and pain it's
causing me right now in this very moment
but by the time we start it's gonna be
all good
that's how you start a video off
positive guys
receiving this data Wolverine shows up
today yeah that's that'd be amazing I'll
put this opinion right yeah
on Tick Tock for 15 seconds 30 second
three minute videos leave a like that's
all I ask so one thing that'll cheer me
up in this moment right now not even
never not showing up in Shield is gonna
make that better he's gonna show up in
your beanie and you're just gonna scream
in pain sweating so much I've been
pacing everywhere full length reaction
watching along pretty sync up with your
own copy of Shield available for super
sexy Rejects at our patreon page team
prepper thank you for helping us set
this down are you guys ready let's do it
so ready glad you guys are all deeded
this is so painful you have no idea
[Music]
previously on my show
yes if they know
funny enough I actually read the office
hey your boys there he is he closed but
you forgot about
the guard frog guard frog
the LeapFrog I think it's his name my
name is LeapFrog I'm just acting like
I'm the guard frog in this particular
instance
[Music]
[Applause]
so in order to de-escalate the situation
I shouted my signature cash friends
nicely done
[Music]
no
and then next thing I know my
inflammable suit with a 900 degree
threshold is on fire oh no I do believe
you are owed compensatory damages
what is the name of the manufacturer uh
Luke Jacobson
Jennifer
do not rush me I told you your address
will not be ready until Friday you want
to look good for your lawyer Award right
uh loiter award
scan looks better this episode I do not
make suits that malfunction my work
speaks for itself oh excuse me what did
you say
She-Hulk will never get another suit by
Luke Jacobson ever again
[Music]
then you shouldn't have betrayed me your
greasy old Buffalo you are blocked oh my
God
are you in court
goodbye tragedy
[Music]
no you are presently without counsel are
you representing yourself
representing himself this is gonna be
bad of course I'm not representing
myself your honor I'm not a fool
then where is your Council
[Applause]
sorry I'm late no problem as a first
point of order I'd like to ask that the
opposing council's motion to compel
production of The defendant's Client
List be rejected as it's not relevant to
the litigation
it's this [ __ ]
I Believe Miss Walters will find that Mr
Jacobson's record as it pertains to
customer satisfaction to be spotless oh
if the defendant has nothing to hide
then why not hear from his clients I
would say that's a gross invasion of
people's privacy based on a very shaky
what if what if
yeah there is no inherent right to
privacy when employing Mr Jacobson's
tailoring Services we're not just
talking about a product here very nature
of Mr Jacobson's line of work making
suits exclusively for superheroes
necessitates anonymity
may I remind you that the sokovia courts
have been repealed oh my God
[Music]
Not only would it ruin my client's
career it could put a lot of people in a
lot of danger and all over one man's
misuse of a suit I'm in agreement with
Mr Murdoch motion to compel Discovery is
denied nicely done so how am I supposed
to wear this
Mr patilio what kind of fuel did you use
in your boosters jet fuel wait a minute
that's not what my instructions said
what uh
no I didn't he's lying don't ask me how
I know I just know uh if the plaintiff
ignored the manufacturer's explicit
instructions then the defendant is
absolved of all liability I'm dismissing
this case am I gonna go to jail
no but I would like you to
and they gave the best courtroom scene
to Matt murders
an Appletini cute
sure oh I hope this happens
ship them ship them so hard see that she
devil what's your story Matt Murdock
you're from New York but you flew all
the way out here for a product liability
case uh Luke Jacobson made a couple of
new suits for me so I owe them one
doesn't really look like it
it's a low bone salting a blind man's
clothes
well I run my practice in the house
kitchen
and we mostly do pro bono work but I do
on occasion take a job with a bigger
client when the bills start piling up
the them part wow secret double lives of
Matt Murdock how does he do it
Jen Walters can use the law to help
people when Society fails
and she all can help people when the law
fails
you're the best of both worlds
dude excuse me he's doing so good
tonight
[Laughter]
we're all feeling this right it's not
just me
go Dance with the Devil in the pale
moonlight
and I'm so sorry I have to go something
has just come up with work oh yeah
it's nice meeting you yeah you too
okay
Jesus so I was at an auction they had an
authentic wakandan War spear
so I of course win the auction A Milli
it's a million
so here it is check this out boom how
cool is that I mean I own that now
smooth no one is collecting African [ __ ]
on my level
love wakanda you know I actually studied
abroad there
really wakanda forever I I that makes me
uncomfortable
let's drop the whole the whole koi thing
because I don't play games okay
okay
[Music]
oh and I'm billing you for the whole
hour
he got off on that now she's gonna go on
date with Daredevil because you wanna
date with Matt
get that dude
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's property damage
[Music]
wow
immediately
wait do you tend to be blind man because
that is
a special method that I use Roger's the
music
like echolocation
Orbeez
the frog is the bad guy here he
kidnapped Luke Jacobson he's holding him
hostage
why didn't you tell me that before we
fought uh why didn't you ask me before
immediately trying to whip my ass
[Laughter]
are you like us
gold devil
I'm Daredevil this is the music
which is very guarantees ketchup and
mustard as your color Escape how about I
tell Luke you said oh well if you're
done making fun I need to save my client
from your client okay let's go
let's go destroyed a parking lot before
oh crap I'll go leave a note
hope it's the first appearance of
Daredevil in the yellow suit which I
think is Amazing Spider-Man
believe in the cause for his goons are
just there for the paycheck and swing
guns whatever
there are 25 goons in the building some
blow Us in the front and ten in the
hallway I'm so happy
healing power of the of the devil
I can hear yours too
your heart's beating pretty fast oh hey
hey
and your eyes are dilating oh the green
light was I'm gonna sneak into the side
and take out the goose in the back take
me 15 seconds to take oh my God
trust me I've done this a million times
to remind me again how many times you've
broken into a warehouse full of goods
remind me again who has a superpower
just let me do my thing yeah and I will
do my thing
you don't have a thing you don't ever do
this
okay I guess that's pretty cool
I love this episode so much
yes but that doesn't mean I'm cool with
being a baby frog wait I thought he
wanted to call us dad Post Yeah man how
did you not know about a baby
oh a hallway fight oh a Wonder a new
well-lit hallway fight it won't be a one
a 30 or 40 year
[Music]
hey Titan that goes on the way
foreign
crew
nicely done She-Hulk smash
it's got a frog light
Frogger
[Music]
hey hey
officers what are you doing you're
supposed to be helping me I am helping
you I'm stopping you from getting into
even more trouble
trampolines that we could leap around
let me give you some legal advice stop
now before you rack up even more serious
charges legally speaking we could say
this is an episode of mania temporary
insanity is murky but it's not a bad
strategy
[Laughter]
I'm diagnosed
he's a lawyer well I'm just a big fan of
legal drums
me too Jim
bad that you thought that would work
[Music]
[Applause]
yikes
well well well I suppose we're even now
you're forgiven
you'll make my gala dress
up yes of course I'm not a monster
I'm trying to get too bloated between
now and then
ouch Luke Anderson I'm so in love with
She-Hulk and Matt Murdock I'm so
bisexually ready for this show I know I
know
statement to the cops
more of a secret identity thing you
wouldn't understand
thanks for your help with
thanks for your help
when do you head to New York
tomorrow oh they have such good
chemistry no don't go
hey maybe next time I'm in town I can
take you out to dinner
Hulk smash yeah
oh he's still got the outfit on hell
yeah that's what I'm talking about just
how you do it after it
show her that billy club
Sensational incredible
then when she's sleeping he's gonna take
a photo of her
phone
Michael Bay
he is the horniest hero
oh walk of shame
Daredevil gets the MCU come
[Music]
[Laughter]
on
yes oh all right and we're happy oh
we're happy yeah damn right you are
mm-hmm we got
ta go wait we're doing the gala that
doesn't feel right
is next episode the finale
this is the big twist isn't it but the
question is is it the kind of twist
that's like another Hulk but this one's
red or like I'm getting fridged
foreign
she is fine I want to look that good
ever educated accomplished
beautiful and doing everything regular
lawyers do except backwards and in high
heels the this year's female lawyer of
the Year award goes to
Jennifer She-Hulk Walters it's her
middle name wrestling announcer
oh my God no they are all the oh
Mallory
what's it like being a female lawyer
so special and empowering I love it
twice the work half the recognition and
you're constantly being asked what it's
like being a female lawyer
I'd actually like to take this time to
thank my parents and my friends and my
esteemed colleagues without whom I
wouldn't be here today do you want to
see who She-Hulk really is oh no she
does not deserve your praise she does
not deserve the powers
okay let's can we stop this
this is horrifying Josh what did you do
whoa whoa this is very real
revenge porn this is like some carry
[ __ ]
don't do it oh that's why that was the
point
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's what they want
oh my God
I've
chills everywhere
oh you pricks
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
damn tense fourth wall break
that was easily the best episode they've
done
it's electrifying
crackled I mean the best last few
minutes for sure oh it's about
everything before that I I don't know
because uh I have a feeling I I need to
re-watch it because I I was probably
gonna love it regardless
no there's a version of this where they
could have really messed it over me
I would have noticed it yeah
yeah
buddy
[Laughter]
now when's pug gonna get some Daredevil
sneaks oh deserved on the Rock won the
stock
Intelligentsia pulled like a Zemo
maneuver yeah I just wanted them to want
her to expose herself like watch her
become a monster
she's not a hero and they didn't even
bring coffee
Luke Cage has done the show yet yeah I
thought Kingpin would have been like
rose-colored glasses but I was able to
see past that oh sure yeah
this was like no this is good this is
good stuff he he fit right in it was so
perfect it was like incredible he
managed to hold on I doubt there's gonna
be quiet okay yeah what Georgia continue
talking about that give us a moment give
us a map moment
right well
I mean for starters
still not over not having my beanies
it's been we've all had a day like that
and and to have your day I remember when
to save the Daredevil camp we even did a
video and I posted on there like you
guys you're wearing this beating all the
time reason why he's my favorite
character
oh man the beating people I was telling
them
that people have always been like maybe
you should replace that beanies look a
little worn out and I've been like no
that's part of the charm it's my beanie
let's just do a tour of the house while
we continue looking for it sure why not
Vlog
um yeah I mean look let's just talk
about the main thing we got to talk
about Matt Murdoch dirt Oh I thought
that he just
um was so fluid with this the best way I
could describe it because he still felt
like the Charlie Cox that we've all come
to know and love they didn't dumb him
down or make him like overly comedic he
fit in just so well with the show and
the world that is a much more
lighthearted tone than that of the
Daredevil Netflix series and he managed
to just bring back what we love about
Matt Murdock what we love about his
portrayal but also bring a new Breath of
Life to the character and I loved how it
was um like with the fight scenes but
specifically when he's fighting with
She-Hulk because there's parts of it
that I do have like very minor nitpicks
on that people will think are massive
criticisms because you don't dare
criticize anything but I have some minor
nitpicks about it however I'm talking
about like 99.9 of this I really think
that the fight scene with She-Hulk in
particular was
cool to behold because I was like okay
they've like comic booked him up a lot
more I'm assuming this is the clip that
was part of the clip that went out
because I didn't watch did you watch I
didn't watch I didn't watch the clip but
I saw this San Diego footage what was
that sorry the d23 you notice what was
the d23 the d23 footage was them
flirting on the roof so it was gonna it
was basically from the end uh no no it
was from the window when she's looking
through we didn't say that it was
LeapFrog so basically her side oh that
was the henchman goon and right up until
he died yeah so we got like two minutes
and we got a sense of their flirting but
we didn't really see any and like what
the action was was spectacular yeah yeah
number four coin monologues for 45
minutes I miss my beanie John why don't
you take this away yeah absolutely no I
I I think he brings a certain level of
Grace with him wherever he goes and and
I think you know somebody mentioned
Kingpin during the credits and I I feel
like yeah if it had been flat or if
something had been off in the portrayal
it just wouldn't have crackled the way
it did and and I think that this episode
from the second it started even before
Matt shows up there's just something
about the momentum and the energy that
felt like everyone was on on energy on
the same wavelength just just you know
Kind of Perfect Pitch and uh you know my
man Luke Anderson being the Nexus point
for all of it like I I I I I do
appreciate that like while we haven't
gotten necessarily all of the legal
Explorations we we would like like it's
kind of mean Jacobson
Luke Jacobson is it
um did I just slight my boy Luke cast
the characters in front of us though
anyway yeah either way yeah Jacob yeah
you know it's it's fun to to catch the
glimpse into that side of the superhero
life and the fact that yeah like
Daredevil would just be like yeah I got
a suit from this designer instead of my
regular guy
um but yeah like their chemistry back
and forth and yeah like a reason to
really root for her to slip into a tone
of Marvel we're not really used to which
is you know the more romantic and sexy
and sort of sizzling in that regard like
yeah there's just so many wonderful
flavors the action with him was good and
uh we got some of the most substantial
again like
I always want a little bit more from the
legal stuff and here I'm like I feel
like figuring out if he was using it the
right way is probably something you
would do before you get to you know
being in court but at the same time like
their whole legal back and forth was
quite satisfying and you know it brought
you know the I've always been a champion
of the legal sequences in the Daredevil
Series so it's nice to get that and uh
and yeah like the way that they adjusted
him for this world felt like the perfect
blend of both and I've heard people
discuss online about like you know Mar
uh Netflix's Daredevil people love it
for a reason it's a great portrayal but
it's not the only portrayal and so a lot
of people have been really nervous about
how is he gonna you know take to the
comedy and I thought they made him
charming and they gave him a humor that
felt very much within character and that
suits a lighter tone but that also was
complimented by an episode that had
enough stakes and weight by the end of
it that it all felt kind of right so uh
yeah I'm a super happy camper are you
dying koi nope I was was listening are
you sure yeah you're dying I'm also a
good listener like Daredevil well okay
we'll take it away right right Elite
frogs here
[Music]
my guy you know I know Daredevil's your
favorite my favorite LeapFrog all right
they delivered and Coy stressed about
his green beans the whole time I am
known for my amphibian love
so did not one not two not three not
four but five things for me that I have
been wanting one it gave me that early
MCU thing where I was very very excited
to see characters that I've always loved
interacting and in this case I got to
see that with Daredevil and She-Hulk too
it gave me Sensational action in a way
that brought those characters to life in
the medium of Television that can't be
done as well in comic books I really
enjoyed the use of her powers I really
enjoyed the use of his powers it was
very cinematic but it also showed their
characterizations the way she's learning
how to fight and the way that Daredevil
would be playful the way that he has a
little bit more Advance they furthered
the characters with the action which is
what the MCU can do very well and it
does it especially well in the medium of
TV or film because you get the space
between the panels you get a little bit
more of a dynamic than just frame to
frame fighting three it brought in a
character I love and made me not only
enjoy the future of what he's gonna do
but it made me want to go back and
re-watch Daredevil that's what I was
hoping this would do I'm very excited
for this new more comicky version of
Daredevil but I was really excited to
see what they were going to do and I was
curious if it would make me want to
invest in those three seasons again it
absolutely did that sound queue is
exciting but it also made me go like man
this this is probably more like the mark
Wade run this is probably gonna be more
like the uh I'm not Daredevil ERA this
is probably gonna be more in that than
that levity but there's still a lot of
elements of brooding and all of those
things that I think are going to be
really special four it was able to
actually give me courtroom things that
not only felt like they were fitting for
this show but they felt like they were
fitting into what could be the dodc and
the greater expansion of what we've
gotten with phase four so not only did
it enhance what the feelings of phase
one for but it's growing out the show
and the MCU is ever expanding it is the
big bang it is always growing you need
to make sure that your pulse is
continuing out in all directions so
while this show has been a very good
thematic escalation and a thematic way
to expand it hasn't really felt like
it's expanded the greater MCU this show
whilst doing all those other three
things also gave us that taste that I
think we're getting from Miss Marvel
that's going to lead into the dodc
mentioned this covia chords all those
things and it gave us a moment that I do
think is going to lead into Thunderbolts
and the things that I said about Miss
Marvel and five it gave us Immaculate
Easter eggs that felt like they were
acknowledging us without being so
services that it felt like someone was
just waiting to make an Easter egg video
we got a wolverine reference we got
sound cues we got a red Hulk reference
we got a lot of things that show the
writers are invested into the world of
the MCU whilst also making it
narratively driven did those five things
I'm so hard right now
yeah surely
I think you're giving it too much credit
that's fun
did a lot for me I know it's changed
television landscape forever
I can I can bust out some uh some
taglines if you want you guys want some
blog lines you want some little
TV quotes
that was beautiful that was very
beautifully I saw your shoulders
dropping like this really have fun
should I get comfortable right now no
man no I also love that it was mature
like I really dug that
it was they they started this episode
off before even the previously on by
going Jen gets Dent Jen smashes yeah
smashes and like I was good to see Matt
like Matt is Matt is a great character
because he's got the Catholic guilt and
he's got the brooding but he makes
horrible decisions because of his dick
like Elektra is a character that's
demonetized the way you talk man Electra
nachios is a character that makes Matt
promiscuous and in being promiscuous he
uh belays some of his own I don't know
what you're talking about
it
we have privy two moments of ability
knowledge the fallibility of man what
are you talking about exactly when Matt
makes mistakes
it's a beautiful thing to behold his
billy club leads him astray he's The Man
Without Fear and sometimes that puts him
in pants that he shouldn't be in I mean
he would wait till marriage
we should cut that out
by the whole point of these reviews is
that they're relatively uncut you know
what the thing about the Catholicism
very challenging is I'm bothered I
thought I was stressed out over my
beanie but I didn't realize it was gonna
be the vulgarity you bring into a
discussion the devil's really gotten
into you today Jesus
intervention hours working on this video
cutting that part I tried to use
frivolity in my language I tried to be
verbose you made me bring it back yeah
no you're you're absolutely right it's
it's my fault I take full responsibility
that's all I ask yeah what I what I
think about Daredevil in this part I
just want to talk about dirty or
anything else what I think about it when
I think about what they what they bought
with his character here too is that I
liked how he was also empowering for her
it wasn't just like hey let's watch them
flirt like a big part of the attraction
was the fact that he seemed to have an
understanding for her that she hadn't
felt truly seen and I liked the way that
was done because he's a blind man and he
was the first person to feel like he can
actually really see who she truly is as
both Jen and both as uh She-Hulk as well
right that line about uh was society and
legality genius we live in a society
I was like Todd Phillips I think he's
been Todd Phillips this whole time
discredited here is Todd I think yeah I
think we were revealed to someone's
trying to hope that Todd Phillips just
doesn't watch this show and never heard
us about it this is a commentary on the
real life director Todd Phillips right
now but I really did like that balance
that you're you're speaking to like
there there has been you know the the
one guy that messed up this way and this
way and and to be honest one of the
other things six that it did for me is
it made me want to like day again like
it may put me in a like what exactly
this this is this is so it's an awake
this episode she's three kindled made me
realize
I love you so much
it is so beautiful dating is awful but
they showed that there is a point to it
like I was married again eventually I
love it the fun of the Walk of Shame the
fun of like that fling and that that
that spring and that love and the
passion it's beautiful when it happens
have you not been dating yeah but it's
not great Wow Let's unpack that on
camera let's do it Welcome to our new
podcast rejects after dark
it's only about to get weird I really
appreciate it I did yeah
it's going back to church you guys when
you watch a rom-com and it makes you
inspired is that not the point like when
you watch a romantic comedy you're like
oh love is real like that's the point of
view yeah this accomplished that while
giving us great super heroics what I
said I stand by as much as much stuff as
I'm gonna get but like what do your
standards should be high enough that
someone should make you feel like Matt
and Daredevil made her feel and that's
beautiful when you're on your next date
imma bring this up please mention like I
wasn't ready to date again until
She-Hulk episode eight aired could you
watch this I just need you to understand
me a little bit better if you if you
think that won't be a potential litmus
test I'm like yo In Bruges Kiss Bang
Bang Shield episode then we'll talk then
you're gonna but then when she's when
she's receptive towards that when she's
like responds positively then she can
watch a night then you're like that's
this is the right date this is the right
girl it's gonna be a positive as much
jokes as I'm making about it you also
know that I I see this yeah yeah right
it's important to understand that
exactly and then you watch A Knight's
Tale and see who she's lost John and I
are actually we actually get weird yeah
it's a beautiful thing when it's so
funny
you gotta understand
s
that it's just so silly I just want I'm
an honest but I get what you're saying I
do the internet clicks on Coy's common
corner for his honesty and his list well
we're not making a list today so here's
some comedy and honesty
it made me want to take it put that they
need to get over this that needs to be
the pull quote call somebody in Disney
you tweet that right now so they can put
that on a commercial
they're just cute flirting this
[Music]
in that bar not only does she feel seen
as a person and a professional but also
she's being seen in ways she doesn't
even recognize because he knows the
double the true double life and he's
something that inspires her and that
inspires her to to feel better about
what that Dynamic is like they she feels
better about the whole thing and now
she'll find a good guy yeah and I really
thought they did a I don't think she
will I mean the whole intelligencia
thing happens
standards are now higher because she's
met a good one and they did a really
nice uh I I almost feel awkward now
bring it let's do it let's get the
horniest characters and let's just
literal horns no good no Daredevil does
yeah it was also in Casanova a movie
about this very thing a great rom-com to
make you feel like dating again check it
out starring Heath Ledger and Charlie
Cox oh my he's getting those fat
romantic comedy wrecks I was going to
say I thought this did a really really
lovely job at orchestrating the sort of
interesting trajectory of them at first
meeting in court sparring verbal
ideology ideologically then meat cuting
at the bar then we go in there initially
pitted against each other
antagonistically in the you know bulk of
the episode as they're going after
LeapFrog and then taking that theme of
you know chiho can help win the lock
hand you know when Jen uh can't help
with the law and I thought they
beautifully personified that in their
initial conflict and everything
surrounding that and then their eventual
team up and the sort of ways in which
that continued to comment on things and
bring the themes with it but was also
just really gratifying satisfying felt
like a comic book felt like a great
comic book romance yeah this episode
fell out and looked like a comic book it
really really kept pointing out it
really looked like an actual comic book
coming to life like it had that Vibe it
had that Flair like a solid 30 40 page
comic book panel and I thought that was
great like this we were talking about
while we were I would have to load some
footage but as we were talking in
between and one thing I was saying was
like who directed this because this was
this was like the best directed episode
of this it was the best directed one if
if even if you remove any rose-colored
glasses any Nostalgia yeah
I think the glasses help because people
at least in the production side because
then I think people go we have Daredevil
we have Charlie Cox if we need to make
this we're good we need to make this
impactful good we need to make people
believe in it we need a hallway you know
what it did it had an intentional style
and it felt very purposeful the
cinematographer even the shot
the funny shot of Daredevil walking into
frame with his shoes off the Walk of
Shane to call it was like that's a
really well composed comedy shot and
then I can see a speech bubble yeah 100
and then at the very end that foreground
She-Hulk shot was terrifying and then
you know they were able to bring it
right from Comedy into that in the same
episode which was genius have you guys
seen The Rage carry 2
that's what happened with She-Hulk at
the end I'm glad you have it that's for
the bad I've seen and everyone loves
seeing the rage against Carrie I've seen
the Carrie remake I've seen the rage
carry two in that order I've seen the TV
remake and yeah it's Carrie Zac Efron oh
no he's in fire starter
it's a lot like Carrie he's Stephen King
it's all the same red
it's red in both red there you go to
speak to your point uh I do think they
did maybe one of the best jobs I've ever
seen with the heroes have to fight
before they team up thing yeah like that
was a really really well done Dynamic
and a traditional Trope I will say I'm
hoping for the Daredevil Born Again
series
um that because honestly you're saying
like the fighting is spectacular I
didn't quite feel the fighting was
spectacular I really remember the
fighting of the Netflix show I don't
think the fighting between Daredevil and
the henchmen was as good as the Netflix
show but I do feel the Daredevil Shield
fight was spectacular yeah it was great
because they used her powers and his
powers in a really cinematic way there
but the hallway fight was not the
Netflix just the whole fighting in
general there was like ah yeah I missed
some of that Daredevil choreographer I
mean I can't wait to all three I thought
this time split the difference well
because there's a lot of editing and
stuff in there but I thought they gave
his movements a very unique uh flavor
and I thought that they did some nice
camera like camera whips and little like
motion and things to enhance uh but yeah
I just wanted to breathe a little more
they have such good chemistry too yeah
but their chemistry is is electric makes
you want to date again
it makes me want to start all over God
figure it all out tear it down
tonight episode 8 is ruined Greg's life
lost his beanie fixtures
just tearing things down man
YouTube it just like made me re-evaluate
everything this 35 minutes was the most
life-changing big experience
and I was happy he was in the episode
but that ending was unsettling it was
very unsettling and I liked where you I
mean back to the main character at hand
because that's the impressive part as
much as we spent most of the time
talking about Daredevil and koi is
having a complete Revelation about his
entire existence
it still felt like he would didn't show
up to steal the spotlight like he steals
the spotlight because he's freaking
there but he still felt like the
supporting character she's so strong
that that was able to work and I think
it's a testament to how good Tatiana
maslani is absolutely that Charlie Cox
wasn't stealing yes and at the at the
end though like there was a tension and
a mystery of like why is this scene
still going on like I thought they was
going to add on some funny thing and
then when they got to the gala and then
you see what the intelligentsy is doing
and what it and what she boiled up to
and then hulked out and the fear that
everyone felt around her I'm like oh
this is this is so much going back to
the first episode yeah with talking with
Banner uh bro I was so also so excited I
was like her name's also better I'm like
yeah but uh but yeah when she's when
they're talking when she has that whole
speech she lamented a lot of people were
talking about uh of that part where
people were like oh here's where people
are gonna get mad at the show and then
I'm like oh they brought it back here of
why she has to always control her anger
and stuff I mean yeah she's a Hulk so
it's going to be scarier as opposed to
just some woman getting mad uh but it
kind of goes hand in hand because Hulk
is still looked up as a hero where she
just kind of like she's being shamed
she's being shamed like publicly in a
very humiliating way and no one seems
concerned about her and I was so
impressed at how uncomfortable I felt at
the actual act like that
yeah no I mean it's harsh and it's real
and it paints I think it made koi want a
date again
that's obviously what I was talking
about I want my thoughts to be leaked
online I would like webcams
I think it does a nice job too of using
these characters and themes in the
heightened world of comics just to
comment on something real because yeah
in Hulk form they're not going to see a
person dismayed by obvious breach of
privacy and and yeah violation they're
gonna see a monster and someone who's
insane or whatever and I feel like
oftentimes uh you know it's it's been
brought up in the show and and a lot of
people have talked about it you know
it's like it's women have to often
express anger and dismay frustration
whatever it might be differently and
manage it more at risk of coming across
like a crazy you you know heartbeat or
something like that and so I feel like
in an elevated way it's like everyone
know like Jen is always going around to
She-Hulk being normal not having any
sort of Rage problem but everyone's
gonna forget about that in this instance
and that's kind of been the theme of the
show right like they've done I think and
it's been you know exhausting on the
internet but I think they've done a
really incredible job highlighting some
of the issues that a lot of dudes don't
look at right like they've done a really
good job selecting certain things and I
think that even the most well maybe not
the most but the the most ridiculous
dudes that watch this show will still
feel uncomfortable at what she's going
through at the end like it no matter how
they feel about all the the commentary I
do feel like that's something that even
the most misogynistic [ __ ] will
agree with yeah
I like that we got a serious fourth wall
break this episode I did everything I
thought they really used everything no
the fourth wall across this episode too
is like this is like the best most
well-rounded fourth wall episode because
like all the asides whether they light
or heavy were were on it there's like
three episodes I was like neutral about
Greg's like koi's back
just see the Glee in his face that I'm
like so because when I made if I had my
beanie we'd be on the exact same page
right now all right my beanie makes me
want to date again all right
I swear to God if someone actually took
my beanie who'd come into this home who
would still
have in your home that would take your
Beating it could have been in an
accident later on tonight I am going to
shut the front door take the beanie out
of my back pocket laugh myself
correct sees you pull it down
everything I could possibly look through
any handyman plumbers electricians who
is coming your home there's been people
coming in and now I I don't trust them I
don't trust one of them any member of
the intelligencia coffee committee it's
really like it was like everything that
they're being he built to this moment
and I didn't get a habit but we gotta
acknowledge the the alt beanie is yellow
it's golden the costume is gold not
yellow and there's a wolverine on the
back of it and then there was a
wolverine reference in this episode
which I did joke about a joke about and
it did happen it did I said Wolverine's
gonna show up in this episode oh x23
kind of did she'd be great Nikki's
fantastic that's a cosmic Band-Aid for
you there it is all right guys look this
episode was great LeapFrog was fine
um
he did his thing Lily Pat he had good uh
periphery details you know what this
look had it had kind of that
strike at times at the nighttime stuff
had like that LA Noire like
cinematography about it at times there
was that Kick-Ass me to drive cool
lighting about it that drives yeah this
show is missing it I bet there's people
who are not gonna like this Daredevil
though
I guarantee we open Twitter right now
because it ain't darkened it's not dark
it's really not but they don't read
Daredevil Comics because he's both
things he could be people who never want
to date again yeah yeah most people
never want to date not grumpy Daredevils
those people are sitting in their
basements just just ruining the brooding
my favorite thing
I just can't get over that it's just
such a good word it's actually just it's
open it's what happens when I'm honest
you guys what happens when I'm honest
it's not gonna happen again expect some
more canned catchphrase always be honest
koi that's what happens the point of it
is these things move you I I thought so
but I was judged
come on and then I was judged you know
when the camera's not rolling that I
will double down
you expect lots of gifts sent to your
phone tonight about like notebook but
it's Daredevil and shields it's funny
but I will take you seriously sometimes
you know this you know I ship she Devils
so hard I love them so much I love it do
you really feel like I judged you
no because it was fun though
I was like oh no did I actually hurt
your feelings I'm sorry yeah now koi
doesn't want to date ever nope I will
make fun of people and tell them until
they're hurt then I'm like oh [ __ ] guys
you gotta find that line well I won't be
dating Greg again yeah Jesus let's do a
patron of the day shadow
John you take it away he wanted to shout
out Chris Wham Chris Wham off because
it's obviously you would be the guy who
would be the man Murdock of this channel
you're a do-gooder you got that almost
religious level of a moral compass in
you but I know you got a dark side man
all right I know you want to date again
after watching this episode so once you
come out here and we can go out Chris
let's do it you and me just kicking ass
and and taking dates out on the city and
because this episode Matt Murdock got
his Wham off yes he did how many times
has your name been used that way we're
here to make you uncomfortable now with
jokes that you can't tell or jokes first
name's almost Christ last name's
wham-off Matt Murdoch yeah you're the
perfect guy Jesus saves and so does
Chris Wham off and hey man you've been
with us for a long time so seriously
thank you for sticking and uh we'll
catch you next month love you very much
hey giveth and he cometh away
[Laughter]
you guys
all right we're done that's it see you
next week we're back
[Music]